those who would repeat the past
must control the teaching of history
benny jezra coda
[Music]
[Music]
throughout the corners of the old empire
the spider queen's web runs
great honored montre dhamma seems
hell-bent on the destruction of the bini
jesuit sisterhood
many of the sisterhood's planets have
been discovered the remnants of the
sisterhood on those worlds scratched out
burned away the surfaces scorched by the
honored matre obliterator weapons
millions of those under the protection
of the benny jesuit sisterhood had
already fallen to the wrath of the
honored matres
but the spider queen was still searching
she knew that it mattered not how many
arms of the sisterhood she cut off if
she could not find their center
the dwelling place of mother superior
darwi o'draid
a secret world which the beni jesuit
called chapter house
[Music]
it has been some time since the
destruction of rakhis
what miles tag did not on raqqas but
before on gamu is what had set the rage
of those terrible honored matres upon
them
something had been awakened in the
atreides bloodline it had been latent
prior to the honored matre probe which
had acted akin to a spice agony
the pain of the probe and the intense
physical and psychological need for
survival combined with the atreides
genes which for countless generations
have been tampered with by the benin
jesuit sisterhood and by the god emperor
laeto ii
open the doorway for abilities
beforehand not seen
their stories out of gamut duncan
he stared at her
gamu he could never think of it by any
name other than the original gidi prime
harkonnen hellhole
she took his silence as an invitation to
continue
they say teg move faster than the eye
could see
that he probably started those stories
himself
some sisters don't discount them
part one
o'draid and the axe wielder
in the opening of chapter house the very
first gola of the beni jesuit axolotl
tanks is born
miles teg
eldrade hopes to once again put teg's
brilliant military mind to use and
perhaps discover what strange powers had
been awakened in her father
whose gola and a strange twist of
destiny would now call her mother as she
raised him there on the world of chapter
house
the planet chapter house was itself
changing a single worm had been brought
to this world from raqqas the only worm
in known existence it had been forced
back into its sand trout form and
released on chapter house the planet was
slowly being terraformed to accommodate
the coming of more great worms and the
desert continued to grow
chapter house would eventually be a
mirror of what dune had once been
by this time he had already begin
learning about the giant sand worm the
sisterhood had spirited from raqus
death of that worm had produced
creatures called sand trout
sand drought were why the desert grew
if they could manage to produce sand
worms this would be the sisterhood's
only steady supply of spice
unless they could find a way to get the
secret of spice production within
axolotl tanks from seitel
the deadly seriousness of the
sisterhood's predicament was not lost on
o'draid
the honored matres drastically
outnumbered the bini jesuit they had
been expanded exponentially by their
venturing out into the scattering and
they were ruthless
audrey knew it was only a matter of time
before they located the hidden location
of the planet chapter house
she also knew that if the honored
montrese did eventually discover the
location of the planet and attempt to
invade they would collect nothing of use
from chapter house
oh draid's plan if such events occurred
was to release as many benny jesuit
cells as possible into the scattering
carrying with them millennia of many
jesuit teachings and traditions along
with the store of sand trout
eventually the different cells of the
sisterhood now themselves scattered
could perhaps produce countless dunes
out there in the infinite universe
the temporary homeworld chapter house
the beni jesuit would annihilate
themselves the honored matres would find
no more than charred ruins on chapter
house
the sisterhood could never risk its
deepest teachings falling into their
hands
o'draid was of course descended from
paul atreides whose bloodline had been
tampered with by the sisterhood for
generations finally before it culminated
in him the quizadz had iraq
his son late to the second would
eventually become the worm god emperor
of the imperium subjecting the universe
to 3 500 years of authoritarian rule
when his tyranny was broken the
sisterhood continued to make use of the
atreides genes though they were wary of
any form of
had been attempts made to erase
prescience from atreides genes entirely
however the success in this had been
limited
oh drains tradies blood gave her the
gift of limited prescience and she only
used it with great caution
she knew that what she did in the coming
months would determine either the
survival or the destruction of the mini
jesuit
in the last novel in the series heretics
of dune o'draid received a message from
the god emperor a message left behind in
the past only to be revealed to her at
that specific moment
oh draid believes that she understands
the message that the god emperor left
for her at siege tiber on arrakis
all things die
but the benny jesuit could not die
before the completion of its purpose
the same ominous vision had repeatedly
come to her in her dreams
she walked across the chasm on a
tightrope and someone she dared not turn
to see who was coming from behind with
an axe to cut the rope
she could feel the rough twist of fiber
beneath bare feet
she felt a cold wind blowing a smell of
burning on that wind and she knew the
one with the axe approached
each perilous step required all of her
energy
step
step
the rope swayed and stretched her arms
out straight on each side struggling for
balance
if i fall the sisterhood falls
the bini jasper it would end in the
chasm beneath the rope
as with any living thing the sisterhood
must end sometime a reverend mother dare
not deny it but not here not falling the
rope severed we must not let the rope be
cut i must get across the chasm before
the axe wielder comes
the rope she walked was destiny she was
the sisterhood and behind her approach
the mystery adversaries who or whatever
they might be intending to cut the road
ending the sisterhood forever
at this point in time
something in her prescience seems to
warn her
it was an ache she could not touch
it appeared to her in the form of sea
child an echo of her childhood self
when audraid was young before the
reverend mothers of the bini jesuit had
such sway over her life
she had gone on sea excursions with the
man and woman she had called mama and
papa
those were some of her happiest times
when she felt the most connected to her
essential self
adrift amongst the gentle waves she
found a place of stillness
lift and fall of ways
the sense of unbounded horizons with
strange new places just beyond the
curved limits of a watery world that
thrilling edge of danger implicit in the
very substance that supported her
by allowing her mind to drift back into
that place o'draid can connect with her
basic self
it gave her the ability to maintain her
selfhood
when confronted with unexpected waves
at this crucial time in benny jesuit
history her mind in the form of sea
child drifted to lampardus
lampardus was one of the most valued
planets in the sisterhood's network of
worlds it was probably second only to
chapter house
the largest chunk of the bini jesuit
military force led by bersmali the
protege of milestag protected the world
lampreys also contained the sisterhood's
most prized school
where the best of them were trained in
the bini jesuit way
the sisterhood's most premier students
resided on the world
the library of lampreus was said to be
unmatched a storehouse of knowledge
likely dating back thousands of years
the reverend mother lucilla also and
atreides descendant and cousin to
o'draid now held the position of vice
chancellor of lampardus because of
audrey's minimal prophetic ability she
could not determine the specifics of the
threats to the sisterhood by prescience
alone
but before she has time to act on any of
it the bloody waters of her sea child
vision come to reality before her eyes
lampress is attacked by the honored
montrese
o'draid felt her chest tighten as she
saw the look in belle's eyes
the redulian records went slap
as bolonda threw them on the table
lambadis velanda said there was agony in
her voice odrade had no need to open the
role see child's bloody waters had come
to reality
survivors her voice sounded strained
none
bolonda slumped into the chair dog she
kept on the side of audrey's table
tamilan entered thin and sat behind
belanda both looked stricken
no survivors
had been fully destroyed in the attack
by the honored matries the rabbi a spy
of the bini jesuit from a mysterious
secret society residing on the world
gamut had informed them of what happened
the axe wielder audrey knew was now
closer than ever before
part two
lucilla and the secret sect
eldrade before sending her cousin
lucilla to lampedus had commanded that
if ever so a time came where lampedus
was in danger she was to collect as many
of the sisters as she could store them
within her other memory by their process
of sharing and escape with the precious
lives and knowledge of lampa distort
within her mind
odrade informed lucilla of the
mysterious people who could help once
she escaped the world
that secret society on gamu they're jews
aren't they
you may have need of special information
because of where we are about to post
you
extremely casual
nucilla sink into blonde's chair dog
without invitation
audrey picked up a stylus scribbled on a
sheet of disposable and passed it to
lacilla in a way that hid it from the
comm eyes lucilla took the hint and bent
over the message holding it close
beneath the shield of her head
your surmise is correct you must die
before revealing it that is the price of
their cooperation a mark of great trust
lucilla shredded the message
o'drade used iron palm identification to
unseal a panel on the wall behind her
she removed a small redulian crystal and
handed it to lucilla it was warm but
lucilla felt a chill
what could be so secret audrey swung the
security hood from beneath her work
table and pivoted it into position
lucilla dropped the crystal into its
receptacle with a trembling hand and
pulled the hood over her head
immediately words formed in her mind an
oral sense of extremely old accents
clipped for recognition
the people to whom your attention has
been called are the jews
they made a defensive decision eons ago
the solution to recurrent pogroms was to
vanish from public view space travel
made this not only possible but
attractive
they hid on countless planets their own
scattering and they probably have
planets where only their people live
this does not mean they have abandoned
old age practices in which they excelled
out of survival necessity
the old religion is sure to persist even
though somewhat altered it is probable
that a rabbi from ancient times would
not find himself out of place behind the
sabbath menorah of a jewish household in
your age but their secrecy is such that
you could work a lifetime beside a jew
and never suspect they call it complete
cover although they know it's dangerous
lucilla had succeeded in following
audrey's orders
before the world of lampadas had been
destroyed lucilla fled with the memories
of the lost sisters stored within her
mind
she sought refuge on gamu once called
yidi prime
she knew that it was there that the
secret sect of jews hid
because they kept their old traditions
they would be at least somewhat
susceptible to the mini jesuit
techniques involving manipulation
through religion
lucilla speaks with the rabbi on gamu
the knowledge that she carries within
her mind is valuable and must return
safely to the sisterhood
the rabbi knows that he owes a debt to
the bini jesuit the sisterhood had
helped them in many times of need but he
informs lucilla that he does not think
that there is any way that she can get
off gamu
gamu at this point in time was under the
rule of the honored matres
escaping this world and avoiding capture
would be near impossible but he also
knows that the most valuable thing is
not in fact her life but the information
that she carries and he has a way at
least to preserve that
initially lucilla insists that he does
not understand
thinking that he must believe that her
information was on crystals and not
stored within her mind
but he understands far more than she
realizes
he then reveals a secret
a secret that the jews have never
revealed to the bini jesuit
from behind the only door in the room in
stepped a woman named rebecca
her eyes were blue within blue a wild
reverend mother
lucilla knew that through her the wisdom
of lampardus could be saved
as the foremen of ancient arrakis had
done so had this sect some cultures like
the freemen of old arrakis have the
ability to sometimes spontaneously
produce women with some of the abilities
of the benny jesuit but without official
training
lucilla agrees to share memories with
rebecca in the benny jesuit way
they leaned toward each other until
their foreheads made contact
their hands went out and gripped the
offered shoulders
as their minds locked lucilla forced a
projective thought
this must get to my sisters
i promise dear lady
lucilla knew that her chances of living
much longer beyond this point were slim
but she was willing to die if she could
aid in the survival of the sisterhood
part three the golas and the no ship
since the destruction of the planet
rakkus the honored matres have all but
eviscerated the telaelaksu race
saitel a captive of the bini jesuit is
the only known flay laksu master to
remain in existence
he as all tlaxu masters had been was
merely a single gola in a line of golas
stretching back eons
in exchange for the protection of the
bini jesuit sisterhood saitel gave them
the knowledge of how to produce golas
from axolotl tanks
and though the process which involved
the use of living female flesh disgusted
them it was a necessity of the trying
times
agola is of course an exact copy of a
person made from the cells collected
from their body after death
agola could eventually regain the
memories of the original person up until
their time of death
the benny jesuit had made use of goldus
in the past but for the first time ever
now have the secret to goal or
production themselves without fear of
play laksu tampering
the pragmatic ability to accept things
which discuss them in order to achieve
an ultimate goal is one of the key
reasons that the sisterhood has survived
up until this point
on chapter house years go by and the
days blur together as the ecological
transformation of the world continues
the artificially controlled weather of
the planet had to be controlled
carefully in order to not upset the
balance dramatically
miles tag continued to grow and already
began to show signs that he still
possessed the mine which had made the
previous milestag possibly the greatest
bashar in beni jesuit history
oh draid intended to have his memories
reawakened eventually
that way they could continue to use his
abilities
by the looks of things they may have to
awaken the goal of sooner than plan
technically tag was not a gola but a
clone a goal was made from the cells of
a person specifically after they had
already died o draid herself had
collected the cells from her father
while he still lived by using fingernail
scraping
the now young boy version of teg was
precious to her
you are a special child odrade said
we made you from cells taken from a very
old man
audrey owed the existence of the young
tag to the telelac zoo master seitel who
resided within the ground at no ship
which had brought the last great worm to
chapter house
saitel had given the sisterhood the
information which allowed them to create
their own axolotl tanks
he was essentially a prisoner on the
ship and still despise the pawinda
witches
it was his belief that the dark side of
the magical universe belonged to the
bini jesuit
within his body he held a secret device
which contained information to make
several goalless
both paul and johnny were there and a
new kind of face dancer said to be
better than any before
face dancers which could truly become
another and not be detected even by a
bini jesuit
duncan idaho is also a prisoner on the
no ship along with merbella the former
honored matre
murbella had grown much more loyal to
the sisterhood and was on her way to
becoming a reverend mother
the inhabitants of the no ship were
under constant surveillance
if escape was ever attempted then no
ship had been rigged with mines by the
reverend mother bolanda
the sisterhood could prevent any living
thing from leaving the no ship no matter
how fast
the ship had been deactivated and was
now grounded
myrbella and duncan now had several
children together they had bound each
other by way of mutual sexual dependency
duncan had also trained other benny
jesuit males in the same techniques to
reverse honored montre's sexual
enslavement
the sisterhood had originally intended
to use duncan to control shianna by
bonding
but now intended to study his children
with merbella
the sisterhood had long known that the
clay lakso had done something to this
particular dunk in idaho gola
many in the sisterhood feared that he
may be another quiz at tatarak
duncan himself was beginning to
understand something of what he was
though he did not know how they had done
it
perhaps the toilet zoo had hidden it
within a secret gene
this duncan had more than the memories
of the original dune duncan
he possessed the memories of countless
dunkin idahos
he knew that the god emperor later the
second had killed him more times than he
could count
his other lives had often spoke out to
him coming up from the void to warn or
suggest
within the no ship in the chamber where
they at first brought the worm from
rakkus it still smelled of spice
many times when he entered this place it
would trigger a vision
he would see what appeared to him as a
kind of net
shimmering beyond the net would be a man
and woman
who would always notice him
they would speak of danger and that
would always snap him from the vision
eventually duncan realized that they
looked like face dancers who had been
the servants of the clay laksu for many
eons but duncan could also tell just by
looking that the pair he saw here
belonged to no one but themselves
no one truly understood the holtzman
effect
they used his formula because it worked
it folded space from point a to point b
not even guild navigators claimed to
know the reason why
duncan idaho was a mint
a gift from one of his other lives
and the accumulation of enough data
ultimately led him to an involuntary
mintap projection
someone out there
has found another way to use holtzman's
theories it was a full mentat projection
his mentat powers lead him to believe
that these honored matres did not simply
come back into the old empire by choice
they fled something
they fled the ones he saw in his vision
the ones who saw him back
who were those people he saw
strong enough to drive out honored
matres
he knew it for a projection dating
he then realized part of audrey's plan
to sin cells of the benny jesuit out
into the scattering he saw nothing but
failure in the plan
of all the sisters that had gone into
the scattering
not one had returned
only the matrix how could they expect
otherwise something changes
fundamentally out there in space
existing outside of the bounds of the
old empire forces change forces
adaptation the divided cells of the bini
jesuit o'draig sent out would cease to
be truly benny jesuit the moment they go
off into the new scattering just as they
did before
duncan intends to escape the no ship but
not in the way the sisterhood expects
but first he will allow audrey to use
him
part four
shianna the heretic
shyanna who had been born on raques was
thought to be dead by most of the human
universe
as a girl on raqqas the planet once
known as dune shianna discovered that
she had the ability to control the
desert worms
she was the sand rider said to have been
predicted by later the second himself
because of her powers the priesthood on
arrakis had worshipped and watched over
her
believing her to be the daughter of the
divided god
it is not clear why the pearls of later
the seconds awareness that resided in
the sand worms of rakis in the era
following his death responded in the way
they did to shianna
but whatever the reason the bini jesuit
knew that this girl was important
they watched over her carefully for
years before finally making her one of
them now she resided on chapter house
and even in death she was still
worshiped as a goddess by a countless
number of humans
shiana led the desert watch program
watching the new deserts of chapter
house for signs of spice blows which
would indicate the arrival of new worms
if shianna retained the ability to
control these sand worms as she had the
wands on rakis then the eventual process
of spice collection would become less
hazardous
but there was also the distinct
possibility that the worms would never
develop
it had been tried many times before to
create another dune
none of those previous attempts by
others in the imperium had ever
succeeded
the worms simply would not take to the
new worlds
perhaps shiana's presence here could
make a difference but there was no
guarantee
shiana was now a full reverend mother of
the bini jesuit but she
like many reverend mothers who had come
before her was a heretic
she was bini jesuit and yet she defied
them
the sisterhood's missionary protectiva
was always at work and they had plans
for shiana
once the worms returned they would
release shiana unto the unsuspecting
universe
she would become a myth made real as
paul atreides had once been
they intended to create a new religion
surrounding her
to make her a living goddess
and they intended to do so using duncan
idaho's help as a mentat
the beni jesuit had always used religion
as a method of control and they knew
that the honored matress too paid lip
service to the worship of the god
emperor in his variant name of gul'dor
this would at least in some way also
influence them
shiana however desired none of this and
intended to escape them
the sisterhood did not suspect it but
she knew the way to disarm bolonda's
minds aboard duncan's no ship as well as
the way to reactivate the ship itself
the other sisters also did not realize
that she and duncan had begun to form a
secret bond sharing in their descent for
the sisterhood
shiana knew that she would be forced to
test that antique thing to its limits
probably breaking it
and that black plas form seeking outlet
from the wild place within her was the
only element of this that she knew she
had to do
call it rebellion
call it by any other name
the force she felt in her breast could
not be denied
shiana was determined to be independent
of the bini jesuit to be free to shape
her own future as she saw fit
every ounce of her being
resisted conformity
part 5
the honored matres
the honored matress possessed little of
the bini jesuit skills of emotional
control
in fact they were prone to fits of blind
rage which in part could be contributed
to the spice substitute they became
accustomed to within the scattering
the substance provided them with some
but not all of the benefits of spice
and also gave their eyes an eerie orange
glow outwardly the honored matress
feigned superiority to the mini jesuit
but the benny desert could see that
something in the honored matries felt
regret for the ways they had lost while
in the scattering
the honored matres also did not possess
the precise control of internal
chemistry that was key to many of the
bini jesuit abilities such as the
ability to resist poison and disease the
ability to slow aging and the ability to
unlock ancestral memories
the honored matres had of course been
the remnants of lato the second fish
speakers as well as some of the benny
jesuit sisters who had disappeared into
the scattering 1500 years ago
likely a necessity of survival outside
the bounds of the old empire
still
something had drawn them back into this
domain
that too was an indication that they
were not as powerful as they would hope
to appear
lucilla is eventually captured by the
honored matres and brought to the world
of junction a world in the gamu system
they brought her before the great
honored matre dama the spider queen
herself
they wheeled her into the honored matres
present in a tube-like cave
deadly sharp sugar wire netting
preventing her from leaving the center
of the tube
the great honored matre tells lucilla
that the cage is in fact for her own
protection
for the honored matries were conditioned
to kill instantly if the many jesuit
power of voice is tried on them
behind the great honored montre sat a
cage containing another being
almost human but not quite
a futar
futars were cat-like humanoid creatures
born out of the scattering
initially they had been created as a
weapon against the honored matres by the
ones of many faces who the honored
montres had apparently ward with in the
scattering
the cry of a futar could be deadly to an
honored matre
futars were said to be controllable only
by their handlers but somehow the
honored matries had managed to tame and
control some futars
lucilla figures out that the honored
mantras somehow make themselves
poisonous to futars if a futar attempted
to eat one of them they would taste of
bitter burning poison that would scar
the inside of the futar's mouth
lucilla remains captive for many days
and she is interrogated by the spider
queen several times
as she remains captive of the honored
matries lucilla begins to fill the
coming on of spice withdrawal which she
used the very best of her benny jesuit
abilities to suppress
the benny jesuit had excellent
timekeeping abilities so lucilla knew
exactly how long she had been a prisoner
of the honored montrese
this was just one of the many jesuit
abilities that troubled the honored
matres for they recognized that the mini
jesuit skill set was astronomical
how do you know what time it is sinking
back into her chair but eyes still
flaming
all benny desert have this ability we
can fill the rhythms of any planet after
a short time on it a strange talent
anyone can do it a matter of being
sensitized
could i learn this
orange fading
i said anyone you're still human aren't
you
a question not yet fully answered
why do you say you witches have no
government
wants to change the subject our
abilities worry her
the honored mantras had powerful skills
of their own for instance their combat
skills surpassed that of the mini jesuit
they moved extremely quick often using
their feet to kill
the honored matress were extremely
aggressive and bound to fits of deadly
rage
lucilla would eventually become the
subject of the great honor montre
dhamma's rage and it was there that she
met her end
i told you not to speak
you dare call me dama
she was out of her chair in a blur
lucilla's cage door slammed open with a
crash against the wall
lucilla tried to dodge but the shigaway
confined her
she did not see the kick that crushed
her temple
as she died lucilla's awareness was
filled with a scream of rage
the horde of lampardus venting emotions
it had confined for many generations
as lucilla died so did the precious
lives contained within her mind
if rebecca failed in her task to
redeliver those inner lives to the benny
jesuit then they would be lost forever
part six
a merger of man and machine
on chapter house audrey begins to use
duncan idaho as a mentat
he has also been put in charge of
training and eventually reawakening the
goal of miles takes memories
he has also forced audrey to realize
that her plan to send individual bini
jesuit cells would likely be futile
some on chapter house consider odrade's
employment of duncan as exceedingly
dangerous
the reverend mother bolonda is one of
them
bolonda is also a mentat and believes
that it is necessary for duncan to be
eliminated
when audrey leaves central on chapter
house bolonda uses her opportunity she
enters the no ship with the intent to
kill duncan which she very well would
have been capable of doing
she discovers duncan within a chamber of
the no ship the golaboy tag is there as
well
hello belle
been expecting you
he touched his console field and the
door opened behind him
young tag entered and took up a position
near idaho staring silently at bolonda
idaho did not invite her to sit or find
a chair for her forcing her to bring one
from his sleeping chamber and place it
facing him
when she was seated he turned a look of
weary amusement to her bolonda remained
taken aback by his greeting why did he
expect me
he answered her unspoken question
darm projected earlier she told me she
was off to see shyanna i knew you'd
waste no time getting to me when she was
gone
simple mintap projection or
she warned you wrong what secrets do you
and shiana share
demanding she uses me in the way that
you want her to use me the michionara
bell two mintats together must we play
these stupid games
bologna took a deep breath and sought
mintap mode not easy under these
circumstances that child staring at her
the amusement on idaho's face
idaho calmed himself when he saw that
melanda had entered mintap mode he tells
her that he has known for quite some
time that she has wanted him dead
she realizes then that she has been
transparent in her intentions he
explains to her that they have mutual
goals
put yourself in my place belle i'm a
mentat caught not only in your trap but
in that of the honored matries
is that all you are a mint hat
no
experiment but i don't see the future
i'm not a quiz that's had a wreck i'm a
mentat with memories of many lives
you with your other memories
think about the leverage that gives me
by the end bolonda recognizes the extent
of why o'draid valued this duncan
the god emperor had reawakened the gola
again and again throughout countless
generations for a reason
bolonda's mntat awareness recognize this
duncan begins to speak to her of the
ixians and the potential for
technological progression within the
scattering
when later the second died the human
empire expanded exponentially
none could say what strange technology
might have risen out of the scattering
nothing is out of question in the
scattering but not within our present
capabilities do you have something less
ambitious
review the genetic markers in the cells
of your people
look for common patterns in the atreides
inheritance there may be talents you
have not even guessed
duncan throws much at bolonda at once
even hinting at the genetic patterns
which led to tagg's actions on gamu in
the previous book where he moved faster
than the human eye could see
duncan then suggest that there was a
thread of late to the second's plan
previously unseen
ixians have not penetrated holtzman's
unification concept he said they merely
use it a theory that works even when you
don't understand it
why does he direct my attention to the
technocracy of x
ixians had their fingers and too many
pies for the bitty jesuit to trust them
aren't you curious why the tyrant never
suppressed ix he asked
and when she continued to stare at him
he only bridled them he was fascinated
by the idea of human and machine
inextricably bound to each other each
testing the limits of the other
cyborgs among other things
didn't idaho know the residue of
revolution left by the butlerian jihad
even among the bini jesuit alarming the
convergence of what each human and
machine could do
considering machine limitations that was
a succinct description of ixy and
shortsightedness
was idaho saying the tyrant subscribed
to the idea of machine intelligence
foolishness
she turned away from him
duncan suggest that later the second
believe that the future of mankind was
tied to machines this makes sense
considering the god emperor himself had
used many ixian devices which pushed the
bounds of the butlerian jihad's limits
the bini jesuit initially is averse to
this idea
they believe that the butlerian jihad
left too great a mark on humanity for
this to be true
bolonda leaves the no ship without
attempting to harm duncan
o'draid intends to allow merbella to
undergo the spice agony in an attempt to
become a reverend mother after
marbella's latest child with duncan is
born
duncan feared that once merbella
undertook the agony that her allegiance
to the benny jesuit would be complete
she would no longer be his
but a creature of the sisterhood
o'draid also intended to have tags gola
memories awakened very soon through
sexual imprintation
which she planned to have shiana perform
the imprintation would also make him
controllable by the benny jesuit
sisterhood o'draid meets with seitel and
employs her vinnie jesuit skills in
another attempt to gain all of the
secrets of the axolotl tanks
he continues to resist and does not
fully trust her no matter what she does
he continues to demand that he must have
his own face dancer servants and axolotl
tanks before he would release his
secrets to the bini jesuit during the
meeting o'draid receives a message from
shiana a spice blow has occurred in the
desert of chapter house
there are thousands of young sandworms
audrey tells saitel that the bini jesuit
have been the shepherds of his prophet
the last remnants of lato ii the divided
god worshiped by the clay laksu were
cradled by the bini jesuit
saitel realizes that the bini jesuit no
longer need his secret of how to produce
spice melange within axolotl tanks
they now have their own continuous
supply the celebration of this victory
is cut short however when odd raid
receives the news that the beni jesuit
pilot claire b was mortally injured in a
thopter crash
o'draid knew they could not afford to
lose claire b at this point
only one option remained
an option which would leave claire b as
something other than human
duncan had suggested that later ii
believed that humanity's future was
inextricably tied to machines
and considering this situation perhaps
he was right
the only thing that would save clareby
would be machine augmentation the
thought of it made the sisters of the
bini jesuit shutter considering the
butlerian jihad the drastic times
however called for drastic measures
clareby would become the benny jesuit's
first ever cyborg
first the axolotl tanks now this
necessity said they could not afford to
lose specialist of clareby's caliber
they had few enough as it was
spread thin did not describe it
gaps were appearing
cyborg clearly though
and that was the opening wedge
the suits were prepared a precautionary
arrangement should it be required for
someone irreplaceable such as mother
superior cyborg was one of those
potpourri words too where did mechanical
additions to human flesh become dominant
when was the cyborg no longer human
temptations intensified
just this one little adjustment and so
easy to adjust until the potpourri human
becomes unquestioningly obedient
but clarby
conditions of extremists said
cyborg him was the sisterhood that
desperate
she was forced to answer in the
affirmative odrade knew that no
objection from any other sister in the
sisterhood could change anything once
she had made her decision
whatever she chose the sisterhood would
follow the butlerian jihad had been
fought and won
now a new conflict began but o'draid
knew that they had no one to replace
claire b
she made the decision to cyborg him
a merger of man and machine
part seven
the two sisterhoods collide
o'draid knew that in order for the bini
jesuit to survive
it needed to change its ways
and she knew that merbella could
potentially be the one to guide them
into that change
the bini jesuit were slaves of habit and
habits had predictable patterns
she knew that this was how the art
matrix would eventually locate them
pride
that was what o'drade saw when she
looked at her sisters and their places
dignity was only a mask
no real humility
instead there was this visible
conformity
a true benny jesuit patterned that
in a society aware of the peril in
patterns sounded worn in claxson
marbella will soon undergo the spice
agony and is at a crossroads she is
caught in between her love and obsession
for duncan idaho and her loyalty to the
vinnie jesuit
merbella knew that her love for duncan
was in a way a prison but she was
incapable of letting go
o'draid knows that the dunk in idaho
gola has been attempting to undermine
them in the mind of marbella prompting
her to study the life of jessica who
thousands of years ago had betrayed the
sisterhood leading to the eventual birth
of the tyrant late to the second
duncan had prompted merbella to study
jessica's life hoping to thwart us
hollows of his performance had ignited
severe analysis of records
an interesting person odrade said
love
after all of your teaching
your conditioning
you did not think her behavior
treasonous
never
delicately now
but look at the consequences
a quiz that's had iraq
and that grandchild the tyrant
argument dear to bolonda's heart
golden path myrbella said
survival of humankind
famine times and the scattering
are you watching this bell
no matter you will watch
honored montrese merbella said
all because of jessica but jessica
returned to the fold and lived out her
years on kaladan
teacher of acolytes
example to them as well
see what happens when you defy us
defy us merbella
do it more adroitly than jessica o'draid
had suspected long ago that the bini
jesuit were wrong in their denouncement
of love even so eldrade knew that for
merbella to truly become a sister of the
bini jesuit she would have to let go of
duncan the benny jesuit is all to a
reverend mother you will never be able
to forget that
as quickly as it had come the dream
sensation passed mother superior's next
words were cold and immediate prepare
for more advanced training
until you meet the agony live or die
when the time comes shyanna attempts to
use sexual imprintation to unblock the
memories of miles tags gola but it goes
slightly wrong
when the attempt is made
teg's memories are reawakened but his
long-dead mother who had been a sister
of the benny jesuit herself had taught
tag benny jesuit's secrets
and also through the method of hypno
induction was able to prevent the
imprintation of her son she had done
this without the knowledge of the
sisterhood his memories were reawakened
but he would be no controllable pawn of
the sisterhood not in the way they'd
hoped
teg had always been loyal to the beni
jesuit however and they did not expect
that to change
once his memories had been restored
o'draid asked him the question she had
been waiting to ask all this time
what exactly had occurred on gamu the
day he set the wrath of the honored
matries upon them had he truly become a
blurred specter of death
moving faster than the eye could see
i cannot explain what happened to me on
gamma my physical and mental speed
defies explanation
given the size and energy in one of your
heartbeats i could be clear of this room
and well on my way out of the ship oh
hand up raised i'm still your obedient
dog i'll do what you require but perhaps
not in the way you imagine
o'draid saw consternation in the faces
of her sisters
what have i loosed upon us
we can prevent any living thing from
leaving this ship she said you may be
fast but i doubt you are faster than the
fire that would engulf you should you
try to leave without our permission
i will leave in my own good time
and with your permission
teg now reawakened with the skills of
the bashar comes up with the tactical
plan to defuse the honored matres before
they locate chapter house
o'draid arranges a meeting with the
honored matres on the world of junction
a former spacing guild world in the
gamut star system
in true bini jesuit fashion they have
managed to convince the honored matres
that the place of meeting had been their
own idea they will meet in 100 standard
days the sisterhood believed that the
matres had chosen to wait so long so
that they could reinforce their defenses
on junction
the honored matress have promised
o'draid safe passage in and out of
junction but they are not to be trusted
as they have shown no honor even in
diplomatic situations dortuzla who had
been sent to organize this meeting with
the honored matres now looked as though
she had been tortured and they had
killed the other sisters in her party
they conducted experiments on me but
that's not important
the arrangements are for what it's worth
they promise you safe passage in and out
of junction don't believe it you are
allowed a small entourage of servants no
more than five
assume they will kill everyone who
accompanies you although i may have
taught them the error in that dortuzla
tells o'drait of what she had seen of
the futars the humanoid creatures that
the honored matres seemed to keep as
pets the creatures have very simple
speech and did not seem to be as
intelligent as humans
the honored matries had fed the bodies
of her sisters to the futars
a futar came to the bars of its cage
after their
banquet
it looked at the spider queen and it
screamed
i have never heard such a sound
chilling
every honored matre in that room froze
and i swear to you they were terrified
shiana touched her to julius arm
a predator immobilizing its prey
undoubtedly the futars appeared
surprised that it did not freeze me
sometime after merbella's child is born
she finally undergoes the spice agony
and afterward duncan can sense that
marbella is pulling away from him
marbella is an honored matre and yet she
is also bini jesuit within her the two
sisterhoods are joined and merged
merbella's purpose had grown beyond
duncan and to some degree they both knew
it
part 8
the battle of junction
before leaving for junction audrey
addressed the entire sisterhood one last
time
actions have been taken that require me
to meet on junction with honored montre
leadership
a meeting from which i may not emerge
alive
i probably will not survive
that meeting will be partly distraction
we are about to punish them
waited for murmurs to subside hearing
both agreement and disagreement in the
sounds
interesting
the ones who agreed were closer to the
stage and farther back among new
acolytes
disagreement from advanced acolytes
yes they knew the warning we dare not
feed that fire
she pitched her voice lower letting
remotes carry it to those in the high
tiers
before leaving i will share with more
than one sister
these times require such caution
your plan what will you do
questions were shouted at her from many
places
we will faint at gamu that should drive
the honored matre allies to junction
we then will take junction and i hope to
capture the spider queen
o'draid gives details of her plan to the
sisterhood bashar milestag will lead the
attack and disguise ships
equipped with lace guns
oh draid on the ground will transmit her
observations to her attackers
they plan to in globe junction with the
devices designed by duncan idaho they
would reveal the location of honored
montre no ships
no one knows however that milestag has
the ability to see hidden no ships even
without technology
it was part of what had awakened in him
on gamma when the honored matres
tortured him in the book heretics of
dune
duncan himself would remain under no
ship on chapter house during the attack
the mini jesuit sisters tam and dortuzla
would accompany audrey on junction the
other sisters of the bini jesuit were
eager to know who she had chosen to
share memories with before she leaves
this is the most pressing political
question because after she dies one of
those people would become mother
superior of the bini jesuit
audrey announces that she has chosen
both marbella and shiana to share her
memories
proctors form little consulting groups
shouting suggestions from group to group
but no names were submitted
someone had a question though
why marbella
who knows honored matres better odrade
asked
that silenced them
myrbella would be present during the
attack on junction as well her job would
be to discover the honored montre's
achilles heel
after sharing with both merbella and
shianna murbella was audraid's personal
choice
but if this venture to junction failed
then shianna would still be a potent
candidate
odrait knew that if her plan in fact did
fail then the survivors in the
sisterhood if there were any would hold
her in contempt
when audraid finally arrived on junction
there could be no mistaking that it was
in fact a former guild world
it seemed to have been changed little
since the honor matres came to rule it
so this was like other junction planets
somewhere in guild records their
doubtless was a serial number and code
for it
so long under guild controlled before
the honored matres that in these first
moments of debarking getting their
ground legs everything around them could
be seen to have that special guild
flavor
even the playing field designed for
outdoor meetings of navigators in their
giant containers of melange gas
the buildings of the world wrapped
around space in a way that can serve the
maximum amount of energy the paths of
the world were direct and there were
very few sidewalks and no plants
there was a dull greatness and the place
was compounded with ixian technology
for the guild endurance was preferred to
luxury or eye appeal
odrade was piloted down to the surface
of the world by the now cyborg declared
the pilot touched a yellow field on his
board just the way the bashaw said they
would a gloating sound in his voice he
lifted the hood off his head and turned
o'draid was shocked
cyborg
the face was a metal mask with two
glittering silver balls for eyes
we entered dangerous ground
they didn't tell you he asked
waste no pity i was dead and this gave
me life
it's clear be mother superior and when i
die this time that will buy me life as a
goaler
o'draid is taken in by the honored
matress on junction while at the same
time miles tag leads the assault against
the honored matri forces attacking the
world of gamut with tremendous force
during this time the secret sect of jews
hidden away on gamu took refuge within
the beni jesuit forces merbella
immediately recognized rebecca the woman
who lucilla had shared memories with
before dying as a wild reverend mother
myrbella made an instant identification
a wild reverend mother not since dune's
friend in days had one of these been
known
rebecca carried with her all the lives
of lempedus precious cargo
she shares her mind with merbella
the battle of junction would be the last
conflict between the bini jesuit and the
honored matres on the world of junction
o'draid comes face to face with the
great honored matre the spider queen
herself though the woman was not quite
as oddraid had expected
spider queen's appearance was more than
a surprise
until this moment no physical
description of her had ever been
achieved by the mini jesuit only
temporary projections
imaginative constructs based on
scattered bits of evidence
here she was finally a small woman
expected stringy muscles visible under
red leotards beneath her robe face a
forgettable oval with bland brown eyes
orange flecks dancing in them during the
meeting however the great honor matre
dama is poisoned by one of her own lagno
who then takes over as the great honored
matri herself
she intends to activate the honored
matre's hidden weapon
technology brought forth out of the
scattering a powerful weapon of
bloodless death i am not logno's target
not yet she has taken this opportunity
to make her bid for power
there was no need to look at dhamma the
moment of the spider queen's death was
visible on logno's face
turning o'draid confirmed it
dama laid in a heap under being unknown
you will call me great honored montre
logno said and you will learn to thank
me for it
she
pointing at the red heat on the balcony
corner intended to betray you and
exterminate your people
i have other plans
i am not one to destroy a useful weapon
at the moment of our greatest need
with tags tactical skills at full use
they are able to gain control of the
star system and benny jesuit victory
seems certain
they realize all too late that they have
walked into a trap as the honored
montrese release their weapon of
bloodless death altering the course of
the battle
o'draid is captured
part nine
merbella's purpose
shianna's escape
merbella and the others are alerted to
the fact that the honored motres have
taken o'draid but they do not know what
is to come
the weapon kills without touching it
kills without gore the benny jesuit have
never seen its like before
when he returned to his examination of
the scene he saw another disturbing
thing
a basic oddity his eyes had tried to
report
very little blood on those fallen
figures in benny jesuit uniforms
you expected battle casualties to show
that ultimate evidence of common
humanity flowing red that darkened on
exposure but always left its indelible
mark in the memories of those who saw it
lack of bloody carnage was an unknown
and in warfare unknown had a history of
bringing extreme peril
he spoke softly to trade
they have a weapon we have not
discovered
o'draid however had given merbella
instructions for a last desperate gamble
should their attack go wrong merbella
does what she can to save as many benny
jesuit soldiers as she possibly can as
they honored matres unleash their weapon
their survivors set a course for chapter
house while she then pilots a shuttle
down to the surface of the world
junction
she announces herself to the others as
an honored matre claiming to have
escaped the sisterhood
merbella is brought to the great honored
montre lagno and uses this opportunity
to tempt her into rage marbella's plan
works and logno attacks merbella but
marbella is far too quick she kills
logno at striking speed
after the commotion o'draid is seeing
lying on the floor
as o'draid lies dying having been
mortally wounded by the honored
matress shares memories with her one
final time
examining the scene without breathing
hard to show how easy it was sisters
marbella experienced a sense of shock
and recognition of the inevitable audrey
lay on the floor in front of el pic who
obviously had chosen sides without
hesitation
the twisted position of odrade's neck
and flaccid appearance of her body said
she was dead
she tried to interfere elpic said having
killed a reverend mother elpic expected
merbella a sister after all to applaud
but merbella did not react as expected
she knelt beside o'drain put her head
against that of the corpse
staying there an interminable time
the surviving honored montrese exchanged
questioning looks but dared not move
what is this they were immobilized by
marbella's terrifying abilities
when she had audrey's recent past all of
the new added to previous sharing
merbella stood
oh
lucilla and many others throughout the
millennia had done
had given her life for the sisterhood
a part of her would always remain within
merbella
warning her
and guiding her down the right path
perhaps some bit of sea child would
remain as well
the matress awed by marbella's
fierceness and power have no choice but
to accept her as their leader as is the
way of the honored matries
but the benny jesuit sisterhood is
divided on their acceptance of marbella
as their leader merbella essentially has
made the first step in the joining
together of the two sisterhoods
she was both honored matre and benny
jesuit and because of it the sisterhood
would never be the same
they would not be benny jesuit they
would not be honored matre but something
else
back on chapter house shiana's plan has
come to full fruition joined by duncan
idaho she escaped on the no ship before
marbella had a chance to stop them
they take with them the young miles tag
seitel carrying the dna of paul atreides
jessica and others and the sect of jews
but as they make their escape they
encounter again
those duncan had seen in his visions
part 10
the ones of many faces
shiana and duncan had escaped on the no
ship or so they thought they did not
know that the others were still watching
the man and the woman duncan had seen
through the net
it is not clear who these two are or
what their purpose is
but duncan had seen them many times
this is where it always happened to him
while it happened today
without warning the sense of being in
the great hole would vanish
then the net shimmering in a molten sky
he was aware when the vision came that
he was not really seeing a net
his mind translated what the senses
could not define
a shimmering net undulating like an
infinite borealis
in the vision idaho saw what he could
only describe as a net but he could not
exactly say what it was
or
where it was
through the net he would eventually see
a man and woman dressed in old clothing
how ordinary they appeared and yet
extraordinary a grandmother and
grandfather in antique clothing bib
coveralls for the man and a long dress
with headscarf for the woman
working in a flower garden
idaho knew that during their time and
the scattering the ottered matres had
been hunted by some power in the far
reaches of the cosmos
he knew that the couple were likely to
be face dancers who over their time in
the scattering have become independent
of the clay laksu masters
using his mintat skills duncan projected
that a clay laksu group and the
scattering must have engaged in genetic
alteration creating the flutars the
human feline hybrids brought out of the
scattering by the honored matres the two
he had witnessed in the vision could be
the ones who had created the futars
futars of course had the ability to seek
out and destroy honored matres they
could use their voice to immobilize and
render them defenseless
throughout the book chapter house dune
the matres continued to reference a
mysterious group they encountered in the
scattering known as the ones of many
faces
and it was also implied that the ones of
many faces had in fact been the ones who
encreated the futars as a weapon against
the matres
and the ones of many faces cursed them
through eternity had caused the disaster
them and their futars
the ones of many faces are almost
certainly the remnants of free tlalax
who faced dancers
and these two who had attempted to trap
the inhabitants of the no ship are
obviously representatives of them
they called themselves daniel and marty
you deliberately let them get away
daniel the old woman rubbed her hands
down the stained front of her garden
apron
it was a summer morning around her
flowers blooming birds calling from
nearby trees
there was a misty look to the sky a
yellow radiance near the horizon
now marty it was not deliberate daniel
said
he took off his pork pie hat and rubbed
the bushy stubble of gray hair before
replacing the hat
he surprised me i knew he saw us but i
didn't suspect he saw the net and i had
such a nice planet picked out for them
marty said
one of the best a real test of their
abilities daniel said that he never
thought idaho actually saw the net the
usage of the term net itself further
indicates that some kind of trap was
being set and it seems that the
inhabitants of the no ship at the end of
chapter house just barely escaped the
one called marty mentions that they had
intended to test their abilities
and that they had a planet picked out
for them implying that to these two the
events of the dune saga have simply been
some great experiment
how long have these two been watching
how long have they been there the fact
that daniel and marty are able to watch
idaho and his companions the nature of
their vessel and the fact that they had
planned to test them suggest that these
two possess technology far greater than
any scene in the novels prior to this
point
the fact that daniel and marty are face
dancers of the scattering who had freed
themselves continues to be heavily
implied in this passage as well
they had to play laksu master with them
too
i saw him when they went under the net i
would have so liked to study another
master don't see why
always whistling at us always making it
necessary to stump them down
i don't like treating masters that way
and you know it
if it weren't for them
they aren't gods daniel
neither are we
i still think you let them escape you
are so anxious to prune your roses what
would you have said to the master anyway
daniel asked
i was going to joke when he asked who we
were they always asked that i was going
to say what did you expect god himself
with a flowing beard
daniel chuckled that would have been
funny they have such a hard time
accepting that face dancers can be
independent of them
i don't see why it's a natural
consequence
they gave us the power to absorb the
memories and experiences of other people
gather enough of those and
it's personas we take marty
whatever
the master should have known that we
would gather enough of them one day to
make our own decisions about our future
and theirs
daniel and marty became independent of
their clay laksu masters after absorbing
enough memories as the mini jesuit
sisterhood can share the memories of
others so can the face dancers but these
face dancers had absorbed the memories
of numerous mini jesuit sisters even
which would mean that they may possess
more knowledge than any single reverend
mother
for eons the face dancers had been the
slave class of the clay laksu
somewhere in the scattering this pattern
had broken
the insouciant nature of the couple's
behavior implies that they are detached
from what is happening in the main dune
story
they appear to have been doing whatever
it is that they are doing for quite a
long time have they tested other
children of humanity throughout the
universe in this manner
if so how many and if they are indeed as
powerful as they seem they will
undoubtedly catch up with the no ship
and when they do
what might they have planned for the
inhabitants
chapter house ends as daniel and marty
watch as the no ship makes its escape
through space
part 11
the lessons of chapter house
in this novel the sisterhood contends
with problems from within and without
much of it set in motion by the god
emperor later the second
the god emperor had indeed been
prescient the sisterhood did not deny it
it was o'draid's view however that later
ii didn't predict the future so much as
he created it he had looked into the
possible futures chose what he saw fit
and then locked them on that path
the rabbi of the secret jewish sect
seems to possess a similar position to
o'draid saying this
he had satan's own powers i share their
fear of that
he was not so much prescient as he was a
cement he fixed the shape of what he saw
of course the god emperor of dune in his
mind subjected the universe to thousands
of years of tyrannical rule in order to
save them from themselves
teaching them a lesson of why it is a
bad idea for a society to put itself in
the position where it can be ruled by a
centralized leader
one of the key arguments in the dune
series
which becomes clear in god emperor of
dune and is emphasized in chapter house
soon is an argument against centralized
bureaucracy it is making an argument
that bureaucracies always become
aristocracies after they attain
commanding power chapter house dune uses
the honored matrix as an example they at
once been the beni jesuit 1500 years
earlier splinter cells of the sisterhood
were sent off into the abyss
never to return
the necessity for survival in the
scattering must have brought on certain
changes within the groups
it was known amongst the benny jesurite
that if you delegate too heavily only to
the same people you fell into
bureaucracy this is why no one was
replaceable within the sisterhood not
even mother superior
this must have changed within the
scattering reduced numbers leading to a
dependency on fewer individuals planting
the seeds for the formation of
bureaucracy
the honored matries had arisen from an
autocratic bureaucracy the early honored
matres had according to the honored
matri's history given to the beni jesuit
by merbella conducted experiments over
their populations research to gain
sexual dominance over the ones they
ruled over when taxation became
overwhelming to those they governed they
developed the belief that they have the
right to rule the ultimate flaw in a top
heavy bureaucracy was that the
bureaucracy becomes its own inhuman
entity it expands well beyond the
capacity of the system to maintain
itself a top heavy bureaucracy the
electric cannot touch always expands to
the system's limits of energy steal it
from the agent from the retired from
anyone especially from those we once
called the middle class because that is
where most of the energy originates
the mini jesuit knew the flaw in
bureaucracy because other memory had
shown them the truth of it but the
honored matres long ago had lost the
benny jesuit power of other memory the
benny jesuit knew that hierarchical
bureaucratic systems were always in
danger not because absolute power
corrupts absolutely but because power
attracted the corruptable
the benny jesuit being the ultimate
pragmatist said conservatism is akin to
death continued growth progress and
evolution were necessary certainly where
laws were concerned
yet we believe there is a morality above
any law which must stand watchdog on all
attempts at unchanging regulation
audrey further emphasizes this point
honored matries have forgotten that
clinging to any form of conservatism can
be dangerous odraid said have we
forgotten it as well
they continued to stare at her but they
had heard
become too conservative and you are
unprepared for surprises
that was what muadeeb had taught them
and his tired son had made the lesson
forever unforgettable an authoritarian
conservative bureaucratic system such as
the one in which the honored matres
evolved would also stagnate scientific
progress
science must be innovative it brings
change that's why science and
bureaucracy fight a constant war
when the bini jesuit discovered that the
ixians had aligned themselves with the
honored matres they came to the
realization that ix was dying
the ixians believed that political and
economic requirements determine
permissible research
mark them well they are the products of
a dying society it is naive to expect
any bureaucracy to take brilliant
innovations and put them to good use
when bureaucracies were put in charge of
such systems they considered things such
as who would be blamed for potential
problems will the structure of power be
shifted will jobs be cost will some
other governmental department become
more important
politics blocks the way of science
the motives of bureaucracy are in direct
opposition to the need for adapting to
change
adaptability is a prime requirement for
life to survive
the honored montrese could not see how
their system was ultimately destructive
to them and the ones they governed they
disregarded the truth to them their
right to rule was everything it did not
appear to audrey that these women
insisted on such a right no they assume
their rightness must never be questioned
never
no decisions wrong disregard
consequences it never happened
and here lies one of the most
fundamental differences between the
benny jesuit and the honored matries the
first rule of the benny jesuit democracy
was no laws restricting juries the
honored matres operated under a policy
of a right to rule and that is why even
if they had succeeded in destroying the
bini jesuit they never could have
maintained rule over the old empire and
ultimately would have died off
themselves
part 12
and into dune
frank patrick herbert jr was born
october 8th 1920 and died on february 11
1986.
chapter house dune had been intended to
be the penultimate novel in what would
have been a seven part dune saga
he died before he had the chance to
complete his magnum opus even so frank
herbert's impact on the science fiction
genre has been enormous countless
science fiction works have been inspired
by and borrowed from the dune saga
nearly five years ago i invited you all
to explore the doom saga with me as i
created the most comprehensive breakdown
of the dune saga on the internet
i wanted to share my love for the saga
with the world i wanted people to feel
what i felt when i first read frank
herbert's incredible books
over the last five years my audience and
the dune fandom has grown tremendously
and i couldn't be more grateful
if you like the music in this video then
you can check out the full album by
james stahl linked in the description
all of the music in this video was
created specifically for this ultimate
guide to chapter house dune you can go
check out the chapter house dune album
and all of the other incredible music
that he's made for this channel over on
his channel link in the description
thanks everyone so much for watching i
hope you've enjoyed going on this dune
journey with me and if you haven't
already check out all the other dune
videos that i have in my doom lore
playlist on my channel
thanks everyone so much for watching i
hope you've enjoyed going on this dune
journey with me and if you haven't
already check out all the other dune
videos that i have in my doom lore
playlist on my channel
i am
so glad that video is done
i am
so glad that video is done why'd it take
so long anyway i mean it's been like
three years you know i mean burnout
i mean i just released my own graphic
novel tadia which is on sale now by the
way you know there's just a lot of other
stuff going on i was focused on a lot of
other books and a lot of other book
series and also you tried make
six hour long videos about one book
series and then tell me how you feel
about making number seven
yeah exactly but anyway it's out now and
i'm just really happy that people can
watch it and enjoy my telling of the
story and also enjoy me trying to
explain some things that are kind of
more mysterious and try and break down
some of the more esoteric elements in
this book because with this book i
really had to kind of like sit
and ruminate with this book and read it
several times like over the course of
the three years since the last episode
in the ultimate guide series i have read
chapter house like five or six times
and each time i developed a deeper
understanding so there's a reason it
took so long one because it's a
difficult book to kind of grasp at
because it's not a finished story it's
only like half of a story that's like
the main thing with chapter house it's
only half of a story it's like frank
herbert
starting a thought and then not
finishing it because
it's like frank herbert starting a
thought but then not being able to
finish it not being able to go all the
way through with it because he
unfortunately died so there's there's a
lot of elements to the book that kind of
like begin
and then don't go anywhere like for
instance the entire cyborg plot the man
in machine plot that's something that
kind of starts but we don't see
where that's going so i just kind of try
and break it down like here's where i
think frank herbert was going with that
you know doing all that and trying to
grasp all of that is really fun but it's
also a lot of work and it's a lot of
research and it's a lot of rereading
passages and making sure that i
really get what frank herbert is trying
to get across you know daniel and marty
you're just frank herbert and his wife
beverly inserting themselves into the
story right well organism maybe that's
true to an extent but it's still implied
that these characters were to have a
great or a significant role
in the events to play in the dune series
in the next book but yeah it's a good
point to bring up that these two
definitely do seem to represent
frank herbert and his wife beverly and a
lot of people don't know this but
especially with the later books frank
herbert and his wife beverly kind of
worked as a team beverly had a lot more
influence on especially the later books
than i think people realize so if
anything the doom saga was really
written by frank and beverly herbert and
daniel and marty is kind of just a nod
to them and they're seen in a flower
garden because apparently frank herbert
and his wife had a garden and they like
to garden and that was their thing and
so it's just like a little a little nod
inside of the story which i think is
really interesting but the characters
themselves and what's implied with
daniel marty is quite ominous and quite
creepy and i really enjoyed in this
video kind of trying to create an
atmosphere around daniel and marty that
wasn't necessarily like representative
of what they looked like in that moment
in the book but like how they make you
feel so i kind of use the kind of
androgynous creepy faces to try and
represent them to kind of
to kind of evoke the sense of mystery
and fear that i had
towards daniel and marty when i first
read the series but the whole thing in
the end was stupid why didn't the
honored montrese use the bloodless
weapon before this why weren't they
using it the whole time if they had this
crazy weapon from the scattering well it
is mentioned earlier in the book that
the honored montrese used up most of the
charge of the weapon when they were
fighting the ones of many faces in the
scattering well why wasn't that in the
video well it's in the video now
anyway like i said i'm really glad that
this labor of love is finally done and
who knows maybe in the future i'll do an
ultimate guide to you know the brian
herbert books uh and just break those
down for everyone
and break those down for everyone
because a lot of people didn't read the
brian herrera books and they don't
really know how brian herbert and kevin
j anderson decided to end the story so
that'd be interesting to do but anyways
i'll continue to post videos about the
science fiction books that i love and
the new ones that i discover as i
continue to read science fiction and
enjoy science fiction this channel has
honestly really been a big journey of
like self-discovery and kind of like
finding my place in the world like so
many good things have happened to me
because of this channel and a lot of
that is because of the ultimate guide to
doom series like i released that first
video told my guide to doing part one
when my channel was basically about a
song of ice and fire that's all i really
talked about because i was obsessed with
the george rr martin books at that time
but i was also getting into doing and i
was reading these books and there wasn't
much
content in the way of videos on youtube
about doom so i thought to myself i love
these books there's not that many people
talking about these books i'm gonna make
my own big huge doom series and try and
make people feel the way that i felt
when i was
reading those books and the ultimate
guide to dune was not something that was
immediately successful when i first
uploaded that video it got so few views
that i was honestly discouraged and as
the weeks
went on it slowly started to pick up
more traction and more people on the
internet started to see it more fans
hardcore fans of the series started to
see it and so i started to post more
videos about dune and that's kind of how
my channel evolved from a channel that
was mainly focusing on one thing to
being a channel that's about science
fiction in general and the science
fiction books that i love and i've of
course discovered a lot more since dune
i was a fan of science fiction and
fantasy in every genre of books pretty
much
before dune but doom definitely
elevated my love of science fiction to
an entirely new level and even though
this ultimate guide to doom series is
over for now i'm still of course going
to post more doing content because dune
is a wellspring of knowledge and
philosophy
um that's just endless and it is such a
rich series there's just so much to talk
about you said philosophy on board again
anyways guys as always if you appreciate
my content make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas check
out my channel for all the videos that
i've done in other series like hyperion
the three body problem which is like my
new favorite honestly it's so good i've
got tons of videos on azimov's work i've
got i've got tons of videos on isaac
asimov and there's so many things that i
want to expand on like i'm going to
start doing more graphic novels because
i don't know if you can tell
like
i'm a huge
huge graphic novel person like i love
graphic novels neil gaiman alan moore uh
alejandro jodorowski's graphic novels
are incredible so yeah there's a lot
brian k vaughn there's so much to cover
and i look forward to the future of this
channel peace out guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you